In the previous lectures, we talked about
predictive modeling pipeline. It involved multiple
computational steps. In this lecture, we'll focus
on performance evaluation, and what are those
different performance evaluation metrics.
Predictive model is a function that
map feature x to predict output target
y. The most common predictive models are either
classification problems or regression problem. For
classifications, the target variable y is either
binary or categorical. There are many performance
metrics associated with classification problems,
such as, true positive rate, false positive rate,
positive predictive values, F1 score, area
under the ROC curve, and many, many more.
On the other hand,
if the target variable Y is continuous, we also
have a different performance metrics. Such as mean
absolute error, mean squared error, and R squared.
In this lecture, we'll go through all those
different performance metrics and explain the
definitions and how they're related to each other.